The jogan Experience like I'm not even
looking forward to I'm not even trying
too much right now to like actually
build the house and be like this is I
want my kitchen or living room not even
worried about it that where I'm the
living compartment is on the upstairs
I'm worried about the downstairs cuz
that's going to be like my shop I used
to paint cars and I want to I want to do
that in my free time again what kind of
painting like I I was I was still very
much like like artistic painting you
mean no like you know paint the cars
like right paint them blue paint them
red you know oh just painting cars
detailing them afterwards you know uh I
always wanted to paint candy but you
need a lot of experience a lot of people
don't know when you're painting candy
you can't just do the quarter panel and
then move to the door you got to do like
the whole what do you mean by candy like
you know Candy Paint like real real
glittery real pretty oh is that what
it's called yeah yeah come on man you're
Texas now you got to learn about I know
called c i I didn't know that was what
it was called yeah you ever go to a car
show and and maybe one car just [__]
pops way more has way more flake in it
like candy paint but it's to paint you
got to you got to be a skilled like
experienced painter cuz you can't just
[__] you know you you always got to
be careful how you adjust your gun right
you you don't want your pattern too wide
too narrow are you super serious about
this [__] oh yeah man painting I thought
that was my thing really yeah I'd get so
discouraged that open mics I'd be like
let me stick to painting let me just
stick to painting wow but that's [__]
yeah it's [__] dope man and my
uncle's like in my opinion he's like a
Grandmaster painter he's been painting
for years he learned so my dad had a
body shop when I was a kid very
small now back in these days my dad was
involved in you know less than legal
business so this body shop was a front
technically you know what I mean but I
mean they got business and they got good
and and my dad hired this painter named
Alfred made rest in peace Alfred [__]
badass painter crazy old guy he he used
to know how to break dance this [__] was
badass Alfred top my uncle had a paint
my uncle Jose and my uncle was young my
uncle uncle was kind of like a
knucklehead at one point involved in
like as a teenager he involved in like
[__] gang [__] some drug deals
whatever but malol had a kid very young
and like Snapped out of it quick just
wanted to be like a respectable man just
do the right thing you know what I mean
right and he's still that guy to this
day my uncle's been working the body
shop since he was like I might be
getting the age wrong he's like 20 right
now he's in his like late 30s mid-30s
and he's still he's still like the guy
who goes into the shop
at 8:00 a.m. we'll stay there till
[__] midnight if he has to but he
puts food on the table you know what I'm
saying right but he learned from this
dude Alfred [__] badass knowledge on
painting my uncle would teach it to me
when I was a teenager my dad also had a
car wash I would go work in the summer
sometimes and I and I get so mad at the
car wash like I hated it I'm like bro
anybody can just [__] rinse the car
off put the soap like it was next door
like across the street from the body
shop so after work we would go hang out
at at the body shop with everybody I
would tell my uncle cuz I didn't know if
my dad was going to take me serious or
not i' be like can you teach me how to
paint I was like I don't want to work
over there I was like don't even payt me
if you don't want just teach me how to
paint have me over here like I want to
sand the cars I want to [__] do real
[__] you know yeah so he teach me every
now and then as I got older i' spend a
couple weekends over there at the body
shop with my uncle
whatever um After High School while my
dad was already locked up or whatever my
uncle I guess to like check on me make
sure I wasn't like getting sad or some
[__] would he would just call me kind of
would to give me a choice he be like hey
I need help like come help me out with
her like all right and you I started
getting good I went to paint school for
a while to get like certified those guys
hook me up with a job like at a better
shop my uncle I would also cut hair so M
Uncle would always be like man just be a
barber like you don't want to be in a
[__] shop sweating your ass off
breaking your back like do something
where you're going to be in the AC you
know what I mean like work smarter not
harder but I was I eventually did that
but at the time I'm like I want to [__]
[__] learn this you know like let me
do this so I went and worked at a body
shop and I worked at one with this this
painter man I hate not to talk down
another man but that guy wasn't worth
the [__] he was a cool painter but he
didn't care so I was the paint prepper
you know start what you mean he didn't
care like he wasn't in there to do good
work he he was in there to just get his
paycheck and he wasn't even like there a
lot of the time man uh you know like
there's a lot of preparation that goes
into in a car a lot of sanding so you
got to [__] sand and sand and sand
and make sure you sand this and then you
got to clean it this way and make sure
there's no like type of chemicals in the
air like you can't keep like the like
armor ra or anything that use for detail
car you can't have that in the same room
you're painting in you're get a chemical
reaction and your paint job will look
like [__] really yeah it's like just in
the air yeah there's tons of little
details mechanic work and paint work
cannot be in the same room really yeah
you just can't you can't have it you
know what I mean so armor all just being
in the room will [__] up your paint yeah
bro if you like let's say let's say you
like sprayed some armor on some [__] or
you wiped the car down and and you
weren't supposed to like which is
anything that was like cleaning product
it you have to be careful what exactly
you're using so you're saying if the
Armor All contacted the paint physically
no like even if it's just kind of like
in the air yeah I mean at least that's
how careful we were like but what is
that doing to you then what do you mean
oh all the paint stuff oh it's killing
you armor
it's got to be killing you I mean the
pain is worse than the Armor we're like
breathing in like primer we're breathing
in like Bondo dust we're breathing in so
much St is there a lot of people that
have like lung problems that are
painters oh yeah yeah yeah even if you
even if you don't like get the lung
cancer right let's say you live a full
life as a painter they've done autopsies
on painters their lungs are like
different colors oh Jesus Christ really
yeah but I mean I'd rather have
different colors than just you know
nasty pink or whatever what if you wear
one of those fouchy masks they they help
no like definitely wear your mask wear
your gloves they help but the [__] is
there you know what I mean you're
getting it in even through those crazy
masks yeah for sure you know there's no
way and then there's different masks for
there's masks that will help you block
the dust from like primer or like from
the body filler but those masks aren't
going to help you when it comes to paint
and like vice versa you got you swap
masks when you're sanding versus when
you're painting yeah so I started
getting pretty good as a painter when
espe when I went to work at a shop where
my uncle's not like babysitting me
anymore now I'm like learning on my own
and when I say on my own I mean like the
way the reason I say that one painter
wasn't worth the damn was because when
you first work at a shop and you're
trying to be a painter you got to be a
like a prain a paint prepper or like a
painter's Apprentice for like a few
years so it's my job to like prepare the
car I like every step of the way up
until it's in the booth taped up ready
to get painted that's when the painter
would just show up I don't know he's
probably just been kicking it at the
house all day he'll show up mix the
paint paint it spray it clear it and
he'd go home so I've been prepping these
cars for like days on end I'm staying
extra you know every now and then if it
was a smaller piece like a bumper or
just like a like a small piece of the
car they just leave it up to me they're
like well you go ahead and knock it out
so I started getting good there was a
guy there man I forget his name super
cool ass [__] guy who was just kind
of like a shop hand like he he didn't
really work on car but if you needed
help you know sometimes you need help
moving a [__] hood or a door like
just random [__] he was there and he had
a Buick like like it was his Grandpa's
Buick like a 99 just regular Buick and
he was like man I want you to paint it I
want you to paint it so I painted like
half the car cuz it only the front end
needed it that was like my
only like big paint job I started
getting good but that's when I really
jumped more into comedy so I just kind
of quit and I did whatever I had to do
to make sure comedy worked
out